comfy  so it it's it's a sad truth but that's  just reality but the truth all the theme  yeah I think  the main like the the Crux of your point  I would say rest on the fertility Point  like aside from that  I don't see why a man would want a  younger woman for a for long term  because what you're saying is because so  we're talking about looks and we're  saying that we're assuming that looks is  when you're at your Prime in terms of  looks when between the ages of 21 and 26  and you said like would that not be a  woman for now that's what I'm saying if  you're basing it on looks which you're  equating to being young would that not  be a woman for now that's what I'm  saying